liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich denke
ich sage im namen unseres gesamten
hauses herzlichen dank an diese
eindringlichen worte
der krieg muss aufhören und ich bin sehr
dankbar dass die parlamentspräsidentin
und parlamentspräsidenten der g7 staaten
und des europäischen parlaments ein
starkes zeichen des zusammenhalts in der
solidarität mit der ukraine gesetzt
haben wir haben uns gestern mit unserem
freund russlands stefan tschök dem
parlamentspräsidenten der ukraine
ausgetauscht auch er hat sehr
eindrückliche worte eindringliche worte
an uns gerichtet in der sitzung in der
ich bärbel bas vertreten habe wurde eine
gemeinsame erklärung verabschiedet wir
betonen darin nachdrücklich die
souveränität der ukraine wir bekennen
dass wir seite an seite stehen mit der
ukrainischen wer uwe rada und mit ihren
frei gewählten abgeordneten unseren
kolleginnen und kollegen die wir von
hier aus
ausdrücklich grüßen die ihre arbeit im
parlament unter diesen bedingungen auch
weitermachen
das ukrainische volk und die
demokratisch gewählte regierung finden
unsere volle unterstützung sowie auch
die mutigen russinnen und russen die in
ihrem land für freie berichterstattung
sorgen und für ein ende des krieges
eintritten meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren die parlamente
der g7 bekennen sich zu ihrer
verantwortung menschen zu helfen die vor
dem krieg aus der ukraine fliehen und
sie aufzunehmen und den staaten
beizustehen die als nachbarländer eine
besondere humanitäre aufgabe zu erfüllen
haben gestern haben wir hier bereits
darüber debattiert werden dass heute
noch einmal tun über republik moldau
aber eben auch über unseren nachbarland
polen deswegen freue ich mich dass auf
der tribüne auch platz genommen hat der
stellvertretende außenminister der
republik polen herr minister schikowski
basic
ihr land leiste trost es in diesen tagen
und wir haben enormen respekt davor
meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren mir bleibt nur
wenig ich bitte sie herzlich dass ihren
präsidenten noch einmal auszurichten
herzlichen dank und slava ukraine
meine damen und herren nachdem wir
gestern bereits eine reihe von debatten
hatten will ich die sitzung des heutigen
tages unsere parlamentssitzung hier
helfen
[Musik]
vor
eintritt in die tagesordnung
vor eintritt in die tagesordnung
gratuliere ich dem kollegen christian
görke und dem kollegen dr joe weingarten
zu ihren sechzigsten geburtstag
ich wünsche ihnen alles gute
wir haben einige wahlen durchzuführen
darum bitte ich sie jetzt um
aufmerksamkeit auf vorschlag der
fraktionen der spd soll der kollege dirk
wiese als nachfolger für die kolleginnen
verena huberts als ordentliches mitglied
des gemeinsamen ausschusses nach artikel
53 des grundgesetzes gewählt werden als
nachfolgerin für die kollegin sonder
eichwede soll das stellvertretende
mitglied der kolleginnen verena hubers
gewählt werden
darüber besteht einvernehmen das scheint
mir der fall zu sein dann ist das so
dann sind ja kollege dirk wiese als
ordentliches mitglied und die
kolleginnen verena huberts als
stellvertretendes mitglied gewählt
auf vorschlag der afg soll als
nachfolger für den kollegen gerold otte
der kollege joachim wundrak als
ordentliches mitglied des gemeinsamen
ausschusses gewählt werden außerdem soll
der kollege und könig als nachfolger für
den kollegen stefan brandner als
stellvertretendes mitglied gewählt
werden auch dazu sich kein widerspruch
dann ist die wahl der beiden bestätigt
weiterhin liegen vorschläge vor welche
kolleginnen kollegen in den stiftungsrat
des des deutschen der deutschen
härtefall stiftung entsandt werden auf
vorschlag der fraktionen der spd sollen
johannes arlt und falko droßmann gewählt
werden auf vorschlag der fraktionen der
union thomas endl und kerstin vierecke
und auf vorschlag der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen merlins perleberg auf
vorschlag der fraktion der fdp alexander
müller und auch vorschlag der fraktion
der afc thema friedhof und auf vorschlag
der fraktion die linke ali al dine mal
damit sind sie auch alle einverstanden
dann sind die genannten kolleginnen und
kollegen gewehrt als vertreterin des
verwaltungsrates im präsidium der
filmförderanstalt soll auf vorschlag der
fraktion der spd die kollegin michelle
müntefering benannt werden auch dazu
sehe ich keinen widerspruch dann ist es
so beschlossen
für den stiftungsrat der stiftung haus
der kleinen forscher soll auf vorschlag
der frau und der spd die kollegin dr
wiebke es da als nachfolgerin für den
kollegen dr karim rihawi gewählt werden
die fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
schlägt dr anna christmann vor auch dazu
keinen widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen
gemäß § 93 b absatz 8 unserer
geschäftsordnung sind auch vorschlag der
fraktionen deutsche mitglieder des
europäischen parlaments zu berufen die
an den sitzungen des ausschusses für die
angelegenheiten der europäischen union
teilnehmen können und dabei unter
anderem befugt sind auskünfte zu
erteilen und stellungnahmen abzugeben
anzahl und verteilung müssen nach wahlen
zum europaparlament oder dem deutschen
bundestag neu festgelegt werden die
fraktionen haben sich insgesamt 19 auf
19 mitwirkungs berechtigte mitglieder
verständigt davon entfallen auf die
cdu/csu sechs auch bündnis 90 die grünen
5 auf die spd vier auf die afg zwei
mitglieder die fdp und die linke haben
jeweils ein mitglied damit sind sie
einverstanden ich sehe keinen
widerspruch dann ist das so beschlossen
wir kommen zur tagesordnung die
tagesordnungspunkte zehn buchstaben a
und buchstabe c sowie der zusatzpunkt 16
werden abgesetzt der antrag der fraktion
der afg auch drucksache 20 10 20 soll
bei der in ohne debatte punkten
aufgerufen werden dazu sehe ich keinen
widerspruch dann ist das so beschlossen
bevor ich den ersten tagesordnungspunkt
aufrufe müssen wir noch einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag
behandeln die fraktion der cdu/csu hat
beantragt die heutige tagesordnung um
eine debatte zum völkerrechtswidrigen
russischen angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
zu erweitern
dieser soll
dieser soll als erster
tagesordnungspunkt mit einer zeit von 68
minuten vorgesehen wären dann ist dazu
das wort gewünscht
kann merz kritisch
auch präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren seit drei wochen
beschweren uns diese schrecklichen
bilder aus der ukraine
und heute morgen haben wir eine rede des
chronischen staatspräsidenten gehört
wir haben zu beginn dieser woche die
mehrheitsfraktionen dieses hauses
gebeten im anschluss an diese rede eine
aussprache im deutschen bundestag zu
ermöglichen über den stand dieses
schrecklichen krieges
sie haben das mit ihrer mehrheit
abgelehnt der bundeskanzler sie haben
vor drei wochen an dieser stelle vor
knapp drei wochen eine eindrucksvolle
regierungserklärung
es hat in der zwischenzeit einen
sondergipfel der staats und
regierungschefs der europäischen union
gegeben es gibt in wenigen tagen einen
sondergipfel der staats und
regierungschefs der nato
und nach dieser rede heute morgen von
staatspräsident zielinski wäre es doch
jetzt genau zu dieser minute der
richtige zeitpunkt einmal eine
zwischenbilanz zu ziehen die frage zu
stellen wo stehen wir haben wir das
richtig gemacht gibt es möglicherweise
entscheidungen die nach korrigiert
werden müssen stehen wir eigentlich
heute als bundesrepublik deutschland an
der richtigen stelle wenn es um diesen
konnten
sie haben
wir haben gestern in der debatte die wir
hier gehabt haben über eine stunde
schweigend auf der regierungsbank
gesessen heute nachmittag führen wir
eine diskussion über die
menschenrechtslage in der ukraine und
frau präsidentin mit verlaub sie sagen
uns heute morgen wie der beirat der
kleinen forscher besetzt werden soll
meine damen und herren wann denn wenn
nicht jetzt eine diskussion eine
zwischenbilanz eine frage an uns selbst
[Applaus]
vielleicht und wenn es nur und wenn es
nur darum geht uns noch einmal selbst zu
vergewissern wo wir stehen unter
bundeskanzler ich finde dass die
bundesrepublik deutschland anspruch
darauf hat von ihnen heute morgen zu
erfahren wie sie die lage sehen und
welche schlussfolgerungen daraus zu
ziehen haben wenn sie allerdings spd
grüne und fdp mit ihrer meinung hier
eine mehrheitsentscheidung durchsetzen
dann will ich ihnen von unserer seite
aus nur sagen dies stößt ausdrücklich
auf unseren widerspruch und unsere
missbilligung wir sind damit nicht
einverstanden wie sie das heute morgen
hier macht
katja mast redet für die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine
sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen
präsident selensky
hat gerade eben eine sehr eindringliche
rede gehalten
dafür
dafür danke ich ihm ausdrücklich
wir die ampelkoalition
sind überzeugt dass die worte des
ukrainischen präsidenten für sich stehen
sie haben es verdient für sich
wahrgenommen zu werden
die menschen in der ukraine
leiden seit dem 24
februar unter schrecklicher kriegsgewalt
durch putins truppen sie kämpfen sie
leiten sie haben angst
sie fliehen
familien werden auseinandergerissen und
menschen sterben täglich und fallen in
diesem völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
mit diesem völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
auf die ukraine hat der russische
präsident
grundlegende
internationale normen und werte mit
füßen getreten
deswegen hat der bundeskanzler
unmittelbar darum gebeten am sonntag den
februar vor dem deutschen bundestag eine
regierungserklärung
abzugeben er hat diese zeitenwende
umfassend erläutert und antworten darauf
gegeben
im anschluss hat es hier im deutschen
bundestag eines sehr lange ausführliche
aussprache gegeben das war angemessen
noch keine 24 stunden her hat cdu und
csu der tagesordnung für diese
sitzungswoche hier im bundestag
zugestimmt
inklusive zweier aktueller stunden
und
ungefähr fünf stunden später ohne neue
sachlage macht die union eine rolle
rückwärts und beantragte erweiterung der
tagesordnung jetzt müssen wir die
debatte leider führen während menschen
in der ukraine sterben sind wir
gefordert wir sind gefordert alles zu
tun ihre lage zu verbessern und die
flüchtlinge gut bei uns aufzunehmen
darum geht es in dieser situation
und daran arbeitet die gesamte
bundesregierung und die gesamte
koalition in dieser situation mit
unserem bundeskanzler oder
die bürgersfrau
kollegin sie müssen bis zum schluss
komme zum schluss die bundes auf
nächsten ministerin annalena baerbock
artist gestern wie ich finde sehr
treffend gesagt in dieser lage ist zu
hören eine echte stärke zu hören und das
wort stehen lassen ich finde das ist ein
würdiger rahmen für diese rede die am
bau kollegin werden diesen antrag daher
ablehnen
die forderungen der unions fraktion und
ihres vorsitzenden friedrich merz
debatte zur lage in der ukraine
jetzt noch jan korte erster parlament
erster parlamentarischer geschäftsführer
der linksfraktion zum selben thema frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich muss jetzt zunächst einmal
feststellen dass sich die empörung der
ampelkoalition dem wunsch in dieser
situation eine debatte zu führen und zu
hören was die bundesregierung zu sagen
hat absolut lächerlich und genuss sind
macht das war vieles aber das war keine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte
absolut deplatziert und
ich möchte schon feststellen so leid es
mir tut dass meine fraktion in diesem
fall den antrag der cdu csu ausdrücklich
unterstützt findet das mindeste dass wir
heute ihre positionierung auch zu den
fragen die eben der ukrainische
präsident dir aufgerufen hat dass sie
die hier darin und die sind ja
ich kann ja sehen dass also die
bundesregierung während ihrer ganzen
pracht wenn man so will hier heute
versammelt ist und da sie ja auch
professionell politik mahlen kann ich
erwarten dass sie jetzt gleich ans pult
gehen und wir spontan diese debatte
führen können das jetzt möglich sein in
diesen fragen ich möchte zum zweiten
anmerken warum ich das wirklich für
völlig richtig halte dass wir darüber
diskutieren und katja mast wir hatten
eine debatte unter den parlamentarischen
geschäftsführern über die tagesordnung
sehr wohl und es gab dem antrag des
kollegen frei hier diese debatte zu
führen die form einer fraktion
ausdrücklich unterstützt worden ist so
ist die sachlage die schrift nicht was
ihr sagen so geht es nicht und was ich
auch schon kollegen gehandelt fast schon
sehr interessant finde also ausgerechnet
die fraktion fahren fdp und grüne sie
und wir waren ja noch von 150 tagen in
einer anderen situation wo sie
grundsätzlich mit uns dafür gestritten
haben dass die bundesregierung hier
rechenschaft ablegen solchen fragen und
das ist auf einmal vorbei und sind ist
verloren
letzter punkt
letzter punkt den ich ansprechen möchte
ist sie kriegen das noch nun mit man
muss seinen kindern erklären dass wir
auf einmal wieder krieg in europa die
leute sprechen darüber es gibt große
angst und wir sind eine situation wo sie
herr bundeskanzler das größte
militarisierung und auf rüstungsprogramm
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland angekündigt haben so ist es
gewesen wovon ihre fraktion bis auf die
erste reihe nicht nur was lustig ist das
mindeste dass wir darüber diskutieren
die ihre pläne dazu sind sowohl das
mindeste warum das bewährte euro
sonderformen dazu steht und abschließend
tage ich als christ und auch wirklich
kein zacken aus der krone werden wird
hier diese debatte führen und ich will
ich schon sagen also auch diese
sicherlich empörung wird dass die
oppositionsfraktion er einen antrag
stellt ist wirklich lächerlich da will
ich nochmal eins sagen sie müssen wir
aufpassen dass sie nicht nach 100 tagen
schon so arrogant sind wie andere nach
16 jahren um das auch in allerlei zu
sein
zu wort gemeldet hat sich jetzt noch die
kollegin britta haßelmann für bündnis 90
die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
finde es sehr bedauerlich dass dem
parlament heute morgen nicht gelungen
ist in gänze
die rede des präsidenten der ukraine
einfach auf sich wirken zu lassen
[Applaus]
und in der parlamentarischen debatte
so
haben sie jetzt genug geschrieben da
hinten kommen sie doch nach vorne
meine damen und herren nicht fangen noch
mal an den offenbar hat der vorsitzende
der cdu/csu-fraktion
diese situation genutzt um seiner
fraktion so richtig einzuheizen
dass man wollte aus der lage was machen
muss ich habe deshalb gesagt ich
bedauere es dass das parlament nicht die
kraft gefunden hat der rede des
präsidenten
der ukraine mit würde und muss mit
respekt einfach zuzuhören und die
debatten und die debatten
sowie gemeinsam mit ihrer fraktion
vereinbart gestern mittag als das
parlament hier seine sitzung begonnen
hat hat er märz frei hat dobrindt ich
kann sie jetzt alle aufzählen haben der
tagesordnung die wir vereinbart haben
gestern eine debatte zu führen
zur lage des angriffskriegs putin auf
die ukraine und heute eine weitere
debatte zu führen zugestimmt es ist so
sie haben gestern der tagesordnung
zugestimmt und vor raich
und zur wahrheit gehört auf
und zur wahrheit gehört auch und das ist
eigentlich der situation unangemessen
ich habe lange überlegt ob wir für die
fraktion überhaupt hier reden weil wir
es einfach unmöglich finden was die
cdu/csu aus dieser situation macht meine
damen und herren
bis zum beginn der sitzung dieser
sitzung jetzt bis zum beginn der
würdigen rede die wir alle respektvoll
aufgenommen haben des präsidenten der
ukraine war die cdu/csu nicht in der
lage uns zu sagen
ob sie eine geschäftsordnungsdebatte
wünscht oder nicht das wohl man sich
offen halten meine damen und herren das
kann man im parlament zu machen ja aber
da sieht man doch was hier gesucht wird
nicht die debatte in der sache sondern
die
und er erklärt der wert
des
enttäuscht
dass sie nicht in der lage sind die
auseinandersetzung in der sache zu
suchen wenn wir heute
[Applaus]
zudem liegen was mein button zeitpunkt
darüber sprechen denn das werden wir
später atv hatte man mir sie sind einer
der redner sie müssten bitte faxen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herr baumann hat sich gemeldet und herr
dürr hat sich gemeldet ich gebe herrn
baumann das wort und dann hätte
dann baumann erster parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer der fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir haben jetzt die bewegenden worte des
ukrainischen präsidenten gehört und was
macht dieses parlament heraus die cdu
hat der tagesordnung zugestimmt jetzt
auf einmal will sie ablehnen wenn sie
wirklich konsistent das verfolgt hätten
hätten sie der tagesordnung nicht
zustimmen dürfen sie haben ja ein
klamauk draus gemacht dass es der sache
völlig unangemessen herr merz
ansonsten haben wir hier tag für tag und
sitzungswoche für sitzungswoche themen
wie wichtig sind die wichtiger sind aber
heute haben wir ein thema da geht es um
krieg und frieden in diesem haus und
wenn wir dann einen staatspräsidenten
haben aus einem landtag angegriffen
worden ist und wenn die bekundung in
alle richtungen sind wie bewegend sei
und wie mitnehmen und wie wichtig dass
unsere reaktion darauf ist oder machen
wir gar nicht so machen jetzt impfschutz
gesetz oder das kann auch nicht sagen
meine damen und herren wir müssen die
debatte wenigstens aufsetzen und der
bundeskanzler muss sich hier zu wort
melden und sagen wo es lang gehen soll
in reaktion auf den präsidenten das
verlangt der respekt
christian dürr für die fdp-fraktion
und ist gern durch ist der vorsitzende
der fdp-fraktion und dürfte dann der
letzte redner in dieser
geschäftsordnungsdebatte sein frau
präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kollegen und kollegen ich könnte jetzt
sagen herr kollege merz dass der
deutsche bundestag anders als sie es
gerade dargestellt hat in dieser woche
selbstverständlich mehrfach über den
furchtbaren angriffskrieg in der ukraine
sprechen wird und nicht nur der deutsche
bundestag im plenum in seinen
ausschüssen und wir als demokraten auch
in der öffentlichkeit ich könnte an
dieser stelle anführen herr kollege merz
dass das britische unterhaus und der us
amerikanische kongress danach keine
parteipolitische aussprache geführt hat
über die rede des präsidenten
und
könnt ihr kollege merz sind noch einmal
betonen dass was die kolleginnen und
kollegen hasselmann und
marsberg gesagt haben
ich könnte an dieser stelle aus führen
dass in kenntnis der rede des
präsidenten der ukraine heute morgen
ihre fraktion gestern dieser
tagesordnung zugestimmt haben herr merz
ich könnte unterstreichen
dass sie all das wussten vor dieser
debatte sie wussten ist gestern morgen
sie wussten es gestern nachmittag herr
merz die kronzeugen die gerade für sie
hier gesprochen haben das spricht bände
aus meiner sicht ich teile einer
auffassung herr merz ja wir hätten
sicherlich das hätte ihre fraktion
beantragen können eine unterbrechung der
sitzung machen können bevor wir in die
reguläre tagesordnung einsteigen aber
herr merz das was sie gerade gemacht
haben gerade vor dem hintergrund der
einigkeit der demokraten in diesem haus
was diesen angriffskrieg betrifft liebe
kollegen kollegen vor diesem hintergrund
herr merz war das ein unwürdiges
schauspiel dass ihre fraktion heute
morgen auf ein unwürdiges schauspiel
[Applaus]
herr kollege merz was die bewertung
dieses angriffskrieges betrifft sind
unsere fraktionen die fraktion der ampel
koalition ihrer fraktion in wahrheit
nicht auseinander umso mehr umso mehr
herr kollege merz fordere ich sie auf
weil wir werden diese debatten
mutmaßlich leider in den kommenden tagen
und wochen öfter haben fordere ich sie
auf solche parteipolitischen spielchen
zu unterlassen das macht keinen sinn
herr merz ist schade denn gemeinsam ein
wenig anheben